i want to bring up this clip from uh tom
elliott on twitter oh yeah stephen
colbert he says i know what his name
actually is he says today the average
price of gas in america had an all-time
record high of over four dollars a
gallon okay that stings but a clean
conscience is worth a buck or two it's
important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon heck i'm willing to pay
15 a gallon because i drive a tesla
i don't i don't want a pro-abortion
capital don't talk to me about a clean
conscience maybe
what does he mean by clean conscience
what is that no clue what is that
reference to i don't know climate change
or ukraine one of the two yeah well why
would it be climate change electric
vehicles buying less gas he didn't he
didn't say anything about yeah he said
he said buying gas this is ukraine you
don't have a clean so it's russia except
the price of gas isn't going up right
now because of russia
we only just today banned imports of
russian energy so this is colbert
manipulating you manipulating regular
people but i'd like to point out as i
stated a moment ago why should i care if
a bunch of npcs sing in the audience go
ha ha ha ha ha ha at a guy who's lying
well there's a thing that comes up that
says laugh it's like blinks so they know
when they're cued to laugh and clap it's
it's all theater and then literally in a
theater and then them laughing and
clapping cues the audience to know that
they're supposed to laugh and clap yep
and you know it also goes to show just
how out of touch you know the elite in
this country is with regular people you
know stephen colbert's worth millions
and millions of dollars if the price of
gas goes up it's not going to affect him
as much as it is somebody who has to
spend like 20 30 on their gas tank to
get to work every day how about a
progressive cost of gas so the richer
you are the more you have to pay when
you go to the pond and i saw i saw this
one i'm kind of joking because i don't
want them to track people's income but
how about that there's a meme uh it's
from cat turd and he said there should
be two different uh gas pumps those who
voted for for trump pay two dollars and
those voters voted for by didn't pay
colbert just said he wouldn't mind
paying 15 a gallon and he can afford it
well because no because he drives a
tesla because he can afford a tesla i
mean how do you say something like that
and not think does this make me sound
ridiculously out of time
yeah you know what he should have said
he's nothing
today the average average gas price in
america had an all-time record of four
dollars a gallon
let them eat cake
exactly let the let them use electric
cars that's right
he basically said that's literally what
he said why don't you just drive a sixty
thousand dollar tesla why don't you just
get your testimony
judge said the same thing twice once in
november and then once again monday
it's like
maybe it's because people can't afford a
forty thousand dollar car maybe like the
economy is the worst that's ever been
like i don't know when someone takes an
injury that's not the moment to start
like shaming them about getting healthy
when they're hurting that's not when
there was also there was also a time
like years ago when he was on comedy
central where stephen colbert was
actually funny yeah like late
night long time ago
and late night comedy has just become
trash and the reason it's become trash
is because one it's not even comedy
anymore and it's too
comedy is supposed to challenge
people and make fun of the people in
power and it's because these people have
essentially just become puppets of the
powerful
yeah i was looking at the snl lineup did
you guys catch that the last snl no i
think it was like ukraine i got to find
out exactly what they're talking about
it's all the stuff you think covet
ukraine what else is on there and it's
not it's not humor anymore it's not it's
like it's reinforcing hey everybody
russia invaded ukraine
and then everyone's like
they're clapping and it's like that's
bad
this strikes me it's just another way to
inject the idea that this is russia's
fault but somebody was saying earlier
today i forget who i was listening to
it's something like msnbc they're like
no gas prices have been rising since the
start of the year and i was going to say
too that if you can't afford to pay for
four dollar a gallon gas like most of us
can't odds are pretty freaking good that
you also can't afford an electric
vehicle and this is not the time to
shame people for not being able to drive
itself
but what's sad about that is that is
what members of the biden administration
are saying between biden and pete
bootage they're telling people that if
you're worried about the price of gas to
buy an electric car the average electric
car costs like 55 000
and the median household income in
america is like only 10 000 more right
and that's what these people are telling
us to do that if you can't afford gas
you should buy a car that you can't
afford if you're homeless just buy a
home
how hard could it be why don't what are
you doing aren't you buying houses
homeless people
it's so simple it was simple the whole
time i mean
a gallon of gas is going to cost
this is what the left does with the
homelessness problem they're like did
you know there are more empty houses
that homeless people let's just put the
homeless people in the houses and it's
like oh and then when the house burns
down who's going to be there to help
them because houses need to be
maintained because i'll tell you this we
had the smoke alarms went off here one
day and we have no idea where and then
we're smelling smoke so what do you do
call the fire department get everybody
in the house they got to go through they
got to inspect everything and it could
be it could be an electrical fire
somewhere in the walls we don't even
know so imagine you got a homeless guy
clearly doesn't know how to maintain
house certainly some homeless people are
but a lot of homeless people are
mentally unwell yeah you put them in a
house you're basically shoving the
problem under the rug i'm not surprised
that the the democrat establishment
elites people like booty judge are
saying if you have an electric car you
don't have to worry about high gas
prices yeah well if i was a millionaire
i wouldn't have to worry about it either
so case in point if i was rich i
wouldn't be complaining but for poor
people they're like
how is this solving my problems well
here's the thing rich people complain
they just complain about you instead of
their problems as is the case with
colbert here i think it's uh it's an i i
mean i agree with you homelessness is
mostly an issue of mental illness or
addiction
very often and so yeah and so
that their whole point about well there
are homes for every homeless person
that's not exactly uh demonstrating that
they understand the issue here and
similarly
inflation and high gas prices are caused
by the fact that we have printed
trillions of dollars
and
that results in prices going up because
you flood the market with excess
currency it's very straightforward stuff
and that they're going to sit here and
blame russia for it and they're going to
shame you for not buying an electric car
this morning i bought a bunch of stuff
yeah so i was like good idea man we
we've been procrastinating on some
things because we're waiting for the new
headquarters to start construction so
i'm like uh look we need cameras we need
the new uh computer and the new you know
live casting equipment stuff
i'll buy it when we when we're ready to
you know like when we're a week out from
the completion of the studio we'll we'll
we'll buy it it'll get here on time and
then i woke up this morning and i saw
the news about shell pulling out of
russia and i was like
i'm gonna buy it all now all of it we're
gonna put in boxes and we're gonna keep
it because it's gonna we're like two or
three months away from from needing it
but if i wait it's gonna go up 30
percent or more we should start buying
spare parts for like everything we got
so refrigerator someone was telling us
to buy like 10 cheap honda civics or
something
because then you like they all have the
same parts and you can strip one and
then fix all the other ones so yeah like
if you ever played fallout 3 and you'll
have like two you know repeaters and
then when one breaks you can combine
them to repair the one yeah you know i
learned that from video games so so it's
a good idea teacher yeah yeah it's just
electric though great so maybe we should
do like ethanol conversions because i
can tell you this i certainly will will
will not be able to create uh gasoline
but uh making ethanol actually ain't
that difficult so you know you want to
you want to do like what um
the doc did and back to the future and
just throw garbage in your tank to make
it run right that's flash graphing man
that's what they do they throw carbon
trash into a little vessel and then hit
it with bombarded lasers and turn it
into graphene to quote i think it was
dan aykroyd was it dan aykroyd who did
that snl skit in the 70s where he was
like
don't don't you want to own a five
thousand dollar suit oh yeah smoke a two
hundred dollar cigar drive a fifty
thousand dollar car inflation's not bad
he's pretending to be jimmy carter i
love it well here we go
so if you go by the inflation metrics
um the calculation of the 80s it's
actually the worst inflation since world
war ii
we're also seeing a ground war in europe
which we haven't seen since world war ii
so you know i you know what kind of
worries me is if these world economic
forum people really do want a great
reset why wouldn't they advocate for a
full scale world war three no-fly zones
it is absolutely infuriating to me to
watch our elites talk about how
unworried they are about this because
this is their
fault this is all their fault the fact
that we have massive inflation which is
not affecting them entirely their fault
their sons will not be sent overseas but
yours might because you're a pleb you
don't have an electric vehicle because
you can't afford it too bad should have
thought about that before you were poor
it's like unbelievable the level of
arrogance and disconnection that's what
makes me really mad remember when paris
hilton wore that [ __ ] that said stop
being funny i've seen that me a lot
lately that's a funny shirt i like it
that meme applies to a lot of people
lately yeah and also and also what is
this where we have inflation economic
downturn and potentially world war three
we skipped right over the roaring
twenties right supposed to be the
yeah i was i was expecting the roaring
twenties and they skipped right right
to world war three we got that in 2019
kind of what makes me nervous when we
talk about how trump had the best
economy of all time was under trump and
that kind of sentiment it reminds me of
not maybe not of all time but it reminds
me of the roaring 20s because it's like
just pumping inflation everything looks
great but on not really it's because
we're blowing the balloon up until it
explodes
you're incorrect uh unemployment was
like at record lows they don't measure
it right they don't measure people that
aren't looking for work
that's
true but you still had employment going
down among communities like in in ways
we haven't seen before i don't think it
was the worst economy when it wasn't but
it was inflating and we didn't it was
construed as good because it was you
know a lot more money coming into
people's pockets but it was inflating
that's a function of that's an issue of
inflation if everybody's rich and people
don't want to work you got to pay more
to incentivize them to work right and
that's the problem with ubi so one thing
that happens under a really great
economy is some dude who makes a hundred
grand and it's the most they've made in
a year someone comes home and says you
know i want you to do this job for me
the market rate is two grand he goes i
don't need to do it i've already made a
bunch of money this year and i'm good
and they say okay how about three grand
okay now the demand like you know it
costs more to get that job because
somebody already made too much money and
that can also be a factor in driving up
inflation as well so it's like they want
to keep people poor so that they can
keep prices down it's an interesting
control they have to they this game they
play with the fed and so there's
interesting questions you know we had
will chamberlain on i think i think it
was we'll talk about the gold standard
yes and he was saying like there are
some interesting problems that happen
when you have no control over the market
because wild things can occur in the
market
bringing some stability isn't
necessarily a bad thing the problem in
my opinion is that the whole thing is
exploitative the whole thing is
exploited the elites take advantage of
it they use it to manipulate and control
they do punitive taxing they say we
don't want people to smoke sober and
attack cigarettes we don't people
driving cars we're gonna tax gasoline
make it expensive they do things like
that they shouldn't do that that's
that's manipulating society for
political agendas but that's how they
use the monetary system to their
advantage
or they tac they tax people without ever
officially saying that they're taxing
them by printing a bunch of money
and the value of everybody's savings and
their current salary decreases so that
we can fund other programs elsewhere but
it was never conceived of by the public
as a tax it kind of feels like hostile
takeover of the crypto market over and
over again when they drive the prices
down and then buy it back up it's
they're so hostile takeovers are illegal
now because they used to do it with
companies and it was just so blatant but
now it's with crypto it's not a company
it's just an it looks like an asset or a
so it doesn't it doesn't i don't think
people have realized that it's kind of
the same thing as going on silver and
gold are up
um i think gold
someone want to check the gold price i
think it broke 2k let me see but
you know i think about that i'm like i
do like gold and silver you know
personally to a certain degree but it's
certainly not tracking alongside
inflation thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there